انتخابات تركيا بلا فائز ودوله الحسم
نهايه الشهر الجاري اشتباكات هي الاعنف
منذ بدء النزاع في السودان الصين تحفظ على
مواطن الامريكي بالسجن مدى الحياه الاخبار
وغيرها ننقولها لكم من قناه العربيه فاهلا
بكم
لا غالب ولا مقلوب في انتخابات تركيا
والحسم نهايه الشهر الجاري فهيئه
الانتخابات في البلاد قررت الذهاب الى
جوله اعاده في 28 من مايو جاري لعدم حصول
اي من المرشحين على نسبه اصوات 50% زائد
واحد وذلك بعد حصول رئيس رجب طيب اردوغان
على
49.5188 اما المرشح الثالث سنان اوغان
فاثر الكثير من الجدل بعدما اعلن عن انه
سيدعم كريجدار اوغلو في جوله الاعاده في
شرط عدم تقديم تنازلات للاكراد كما قال
انه سيدعم اردوغان اذا اعاد اللاجئين
السوريين الى بلادهم
شبكه هي الاعنف منذ بدء الاقتتال العسكري
شهدت ولايه غرب دارفور بين الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع مع تاكيدات بسقوط اكثر
من 280 شخصا واصابه 200 او 160 اثر
الاشتباكات التي شهدتها الجنينه غرب
دارفور خلال يومين فقط وفي العاصمه تحولت
مدينه الخرطوم بحري الى منطقه كوارث حيث
اصبح الخراب والدمار من صفات المدينه التي
تمثل الضلعه الثالث للعاصمه المثلثه
تقريبا يعانون من قطع المياه وانعدام
الامن والغذاء منذ بدء الاشتباكات
وفي خطوه قد تزيد التوتر بين بكين واوا
واشنطن حكمت الصين مدى الحياه على مواطن
امريكي يبلغ من العمر 78 عاما بتهمه
التجسس عدم اعتقال
الذي يحمل اقامه دائمه في اوكوند في ابريل
عام 2021 في مدينه
جنوب شرق البلاد بحسب ما اعلت المحكمه
المتوسطه في المدينه لكنها لن تذكر تفاصيل
التحام هذا وامرت المحكمه بمصادره ممتلكات
شخصيه تعود للمتهم بقيمه تتجاوز واحده
وسبعين الف دولار امريكيا
والى عالم الفضاء حيث اكتشف علماء الفلك
اجسام فضائيه لم يرها احد من قبل ذلك خلال
فحص اكثر من مليون صوره تم تجميعها لانشاء
اطلس شامل نجوم وكيفيه ولادتها والاحمام
المحبه قام علماء الفلك باستخدام تلسكوب
المصدر الاوروبي الجنوبي لالتقاط الضوء
داخل الغبار بالاشعات تحت الحمراء كما
فحصوا خمس مناطق قريبه لتشكيل النجوم لما
يمكن ان تساعد هذه الملاحظات على حل الغاز
كيفيه تورد النجوم وفقا للعلماء
ونختم من الولايات المتحده الامريكيه حيث
كشفت وزاره النقل الامريكيه عن تعرض
بيانات 237 الف موظف حكومي حالي وسابق
الاختراق الامر الذي اثار غضبا في الاوساط
الامريكيه معتبره انه ضعف من الاداره
الحاليه
بحسب صحفنا ملكيه فان المخترقين استهدفوا
انظمه معالجه مستحقات برنامج ترانس
لنقل الذي يسبب بعض تكاليف انتقالات موظفي
الحكومه الاتحاديه بالولايات المتحده ولم
يتضح ان كان اي من المعلومات الشخصيه
للموظفين قد استخدمت لاغراض اجراميه